hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to allow
me you might be wondering where I've
been the past week well there's an
incident in Nevada many people injured I
could never go back but I'm here now and
ready to do the next review 3d seems to
be everywhere nowadays Dustin but a lot
of people forget that this used to be a
very cheap gimmick before it became a
very expensive gimmick and probably its
ugliest transition was in the 80s and
90s where 3d wasn't really big money
didn't look that impressive and to be
honest nobody really knows why it was
around and one of the movies that tried
to take advantage of this relatively
thick gimmick was jaws 3 also known as
jaws 3d
if you thought jaws 2 was unnecessary
here's a sequel that adds even more
unnecessary Ness crappy effects boring
characters and 3d that's so lame you'll
be looking at your hand thinking that's
flat and of course what I mean by bass
PD is no 3d this movie doesn't come with
any glasses or anything so it's entirely
pointless in 3d this looks really
impressive but in real life I look like
a friggin spaz this is we're in for
people just an hour and a half of this
so let's take a walk I know yet so let's
see what gimmicks they tried literally
throwing at us in the opening whoa those
credits are jumping out at us oh wait
there's no glasses so it just looks
tacky and retarded so we watch the point
of view of probably the world's slowest
moving shark as he does the unthinkable
murders ooh oh fish my god not the
entire fish liquid will miss the little
never cease family again
next next next okay
even the 3d your fucking fish head is
not scary next some of the premise of
this movie is actually a little creative
at least in its setting it takes place
in sealed which I had to admit is kind
of a weird advertising time do you
really want to advertise that your theme
park has Jaws in it a giant shark that
can eat you anytime you want it's like
advertising Disneyworld not with more
cancer but uh we get a couple of guys
who are trying to close this gate or
something when you know who shows up
Oh son of a Birds shark crossing you any
halls I thought you said those tracks
here toppings on the gate up better get
Mike Brody out here actually all joking
aside
what did jaws exactly do I mean I know
he's a big shark but does he just want
to browse the tool belt to stop opening
gates so this one guy decides to look at
the problem at dusk because yeah this
one you'll have the most amount of white
right as he senses something bad in the
water
ah but of course
Jah shows up and that's the guy Wow I
can just feel the fakeness leaving off
the screen so we come to our main
characters played by Dennis Quaid and
John plush they play the brony brothers
that's right
the sons of the main character from the
first John's movies what relevance does
this have to anything in the story um
they're accompanied by their girlfriends
played by Lea Thompson and Beth
Armstrong who like to play games like
standoff which involves two people
lightly pushing each other with their
palms truly a battle of strength and wit
my fly's open you lured me with the
promise of penis beer you owe me a
couple that's right coming up to Baird
um are these two gonna stop looking out
oh my gosh yeah Oh
Oh so punching Thompson go down to the
water to play their other favorite game
chase the cowgirl through the knee-high
tents on the beach
um kinky but meanwhile a bigger nastier
foe is at work that's right I'm talking
about the lowest form of scum known by
man somewhere down there it's the best
car guy a Miami give us 200 bucks for
the good stuff
coral stealers I mean really
coral stealers we have coral stealers in
this movie who's their competition the
seahorse mafia so of course jaws strikes
again but it was to be sure it leaves no
evidence behind that you didn't know
Jones can suffer a straw straw did so
the life of the first dead guy is
concerned because they can't find his
body
so they take that boat that you always
see the Planeteers ears to go under the
water and see if they can find it
Yellow Submarine now get ready folks for
some of the best underwater effects you
have ever seen in your entire life
Wow Happy Meal toys in a bathtub have
nothing compared to the sea in fact the
ship itself SARM what's like one of the
balanced electric shaver doesn't it
worth 25 and hey if you thought my green
screen effects were in present get a
load of this
yeah I bet you did another should had a
cloaking device did you open truck
driver drove last night out there
anything happened to him the ocean curve
would have want him up here that's a lot
of fish so they come across a fake
sunken ship because if it's good enough
for your fish tank it's good enough for
Sea World
and something has the dolphin spooked
but what could it be it's a sharp edged
rod so stick it out to look around they
come across the ferocious animal or at
least the hand puppet version will be my
god is whack a shark so wait an
Armstrong get away bye listen to this
riding the dolphins to safety
they replay the footage about 30 times
to simulate the je sequence as they
finally escape so this British fish
hunter or something comes aboard to try
and capture the shark and make tons of
money off of it
actually that guy is from animal cinemas
now what are you doing here
what's mammal to only the greatest
series to come out of the 1980s let me
fill you in
it all started on September 30th 1983
Simon mccorkadale starred as dr.
Jonathan chase a man with the brightest
of futures darkest of pass so any if we
kill this beastie on camera I can
guarantee you media coverage there isn't
a great white alive in captivity
anywhere if any facility can maintain a
white it sauce if we could whoa what is
up with Quaid's pits
I guess shark attacks given an
unbelievable fear of Old Spice that
would really be a spectacular event no
doubt about dad huh so the overall
SeaWorld gives his blessing as the team
heads down to catch jaws by the way when
did SeaWorld become the Starship
Enterprise
all I can say is I'm worried we're in a
lousy horror movie and I'm the only
black person around clearly I need to
hire more black people
Manimal had the ability to turn into any
animal they damn well pleases so they
set out to hunt the beasts and oddly
enough they catch it jaws is captured
and brought to one of the fish tanks gee
they're not trying to fake us out
lengthened in the first movie by any
chance are they I'll wait for it so they
open up their new underwater attraction
which I guess is supposed to be like a
haunted house underwater
come on that's not a ride that's a
hentai there's no extra charge with this
unique attraction our underwater tunnels
are not only fun but informative you
know it's funny how often I to remind
myself if this was shot in 3d because
shots like that they blend in so well to
the story oh my god they're awkward I'm
stupid so through some really confusing
dialogue I guess the shark dies because
they put it in the wrong tank
unfortunately that doesn't distract the
people from the dead guy who's floating
in the water who see any hole who pushed
the girl into the dead body and he who
does that oh there you did guy smooching
closer Suze you've gotta get a picture
of this oh boy so they discover that
wasn't Jaws that they originally
captured but her son
that's right jaws is a woman and hell
hath no fury like a PMSing shark but
once revenge for her dead fishing now in
the series 90-minute pilot man will
teams up with hot detective Brooke
Mackenzie
Jesus try speaking English to them maybe
then they'll listen
sheesh is it me or is Jones making like
incredible speed what does she just have
a motor attached to her fin so after not
eating anyone yeah she just sort of
looks at him she decided to bumper boats
or more to her liking as she oh yes one
of her victims that's right she knits
now jaws isn't as much a saved King
where as much as she is a light nibbler
but she makes up for it by trying to
destroy the underwater haunted house
yes I can see why SeaWorld want to do a
tie-in with this movie can you just see
the promotional video right now looking
for a summer vacation want to bring the
kids hoping to be trapped in a watery
grave with will - no hope of escape come
to see a disappointing alternative to
disagree so the people are trapped
literally under the sea as that British
guy tries to go and lure the shark into
a giant underwater cage but he gets
caught and is unable to escape
why is he trying to cast a spell on her
expecto like fry wait you can teach me
I'm British food I taste terrible so the
British guy literally gets stuck in jaws
his teeth as her other row of teeth
which I guess are going to throat or
something finishes him on his assistant
doesn't take the news well what is it
when people yell in this movie you can
never understand what the hell're say no
that was real creeping and that it was
really gripping that letter
you can't deny he was really holding on
to that letter Catherine what are you
doing I'm going down there you crazy
he needs eyes in the back of his head
Calvin oh look another black guy I guess
I guess Calvin a fighting chance to
survive this movie doesn't it we got to
see Manimal turn into a cat so he could
peek down Ursula Andress his dress so
even though she's an a giant metal cage
does that stop jaws Oh No
she ripped through it like it was wet
toilet
good lord nothing can stop this killing
machine well except maybe one thing
Chuck Norris even then he'd had to be
riding a shark just as big as jaws so
they finally get the people out as I'm
sure they reenact the audience's
reaction of leaving unfortunately jaw
starts floating towards the base oh and
I don't mean swim I mean flopped having
actual movement would require another
doubling back
fuck John she's very very very very very
slowly coming towards us we're ours to
take ours
the effects for this movie never cease
to amaze me I especially love how jaws
just freezes in time as a vacuum of
water floods into the building it's like
she's so bad that she ascends above
water even the elements of Earth can't
possibly stop her let's not forget about
the time he turned into a horse and
stopped on Robert so after she breaks
the fourth wall she goes looking around
for tasty morsels yeah sushi Pink's phew
thank God I had another black guy I
guess lousy killer monsters really do
prefer dark meat later so quaint an
Armstrong try to swim out as John's get
stuck between one of the walls
oh hey come on now you're just teasing
me come on down here and fight like a
shark so I guess the British guy in the
grenade are still in her mouth and yet
somehow she doesn't choke to death as
Quaid uses it to blow up the shark for
good do we enter an itchy and scratchy
cartoon where the end on a high note yes
what about the dolphins those characters
that play little to no part but now
we're solely concerned about yes the
dolphins make it out as well
which is funny because we don't really
know if any of the people made it out
alive or if they just drown to death but
the Dolphins are okay and that's all
that matters
well okay no it isn't but who cares the
movies over I'll take anything you throw
at me and that's Jaws 3-d or as i like
to call it shit not only are the special
effects terrible even if you have the 3d
glasses but the story is just ludicrous
and the characters are so boring that
there's literally nothing that can save
even if it was in 3d and that's all I
gotta say about you know I wonder the
series was canceled on December 17th
1983 due to poor ratings with it being
put
appearance in Jaws 3-d marks only the
second time that mccorkadale has been
featured in something that is featured
sharks and the jaws theme now am I
saying that there's a scene from animal
where he turns into a shark to go after
a bad guy and it plays the jaws theme
yeah that's exactly what I'm saying